louis i'm very curious what the role was
that
you did not get that kind of paved the
way for mortal kombat can you tell us
what it was
uh i i can say it because i think it
came out already um but uh
it was for the role of uh shang chi in
the marvel film
throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament
of champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
[Applause]
as mortal kombat where does getting the
call saying hey you're going to be in
the next mortal kombat where does that
rank what did that moment feel like
that was a crazy moment you know i i was
um
i had just gotten back from japan i just
lost a crazy job
a really really high caliber level job
and
i came back and um i was on another
plane i heard that news on a plane to
japan and i was like devastated
i did this meditation course and i came
back and then um
i was on my way to nashville tennessee
to race cars
at nascar and i was like maybe i'm the
first asian person to ever be
in this in this place before and all of
a sudden i get a phone call
uh saying that i got the role and i
ended up not doing it because i was like
oh i need to i need to be safe now
because i got an opportunity here
yeah i mean um it was a surreal
experience and um
i can't describe to you in words what it
felt like
uh but um it felt like a
crazy opportunity and a crazy challenge
at the same time
and um i was inspired inspired after
that moment
i'm very curious what the role was that
you did not get that kind of paved the
way for mortal kombat can you tell us
what it was
uh i i can say it because i think it
came out already
um but uh it was for the role of uh
shangti
in the marvel film and um a friend of
mine simon got that part and i think
he's gonna do a fantastic job with the
material
and um everything happens at the right
time at the right reason and looking
back
on on everything that played out i
wouldn't change it in
for it for an instant it had the same
marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
and i'm very grateful that just diverse
people are leading you know these
amazing films
and uh to see our faces um that are
usually
uh looked looked over and looked past
and to have that opportunity
to be a part of that change is that i
didn't get to see when i was growing up
i'm honored to do that and i'm and i'm
happy for everybody else
you